- The plucky YouTubers
behind the channel MxR Plays,
claim that they're being
extorted by Jukin Media,
all for uploading some
reaction videos to YouTube.
On the other hand, Jukin says
that MxR committed copyright infringement
by using their videos without permission.
Who's right?
Well, I have some good news
and some bad news for MxR.
The good news is that
they might have a defense
to Jukin's claims.
The bad news is that they
might not have a defense.
I have worse news still,
they might not just be
liable for the $6,000
that Jukin demands, but
actually $600,000 or more.
And the worst news of all,
there's no way to figure
out which one is right
until they go to court
and spend potentially
a million dollars on attorneys fees.
So who's right in this whole
reaction video debacle?
Well, let's think like a lawyer.
Hey, Legal Eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because I've received
hundreds of emails and DMs
about this particular case
and this particular video.
This case has it all.
A little guy who's getting pushed around,
a bad guy who might be a troll,
the intricacies of
copyright law, huge stakes
and thousands of teenage legal experts.
So let me give you a
quick summary of the facts
as I understand them,
because they're going to be necessary
to make any kind of legal judgment here.
A few days ago, the
YouTube channel, MxR Plays,
posted a video to YouTube claiming
that they were being extorted.
- Something called the Jukin Media.
It feels kind of weird talking about it
'cause it just happened.
- Apparently, a few weeks or months ago,
they have been posting various reactions
on their channel.
They would take viral and meme video clips
from the internet and the two of them,
I assume that they are a
boyfriend and girlfriend couple,
would react to them in some ways.
Sometimes it would be the
man that was responding
and reacting to the clip.
Sometimes it was the woman in MxR,
not unlike many YouTube channels
that are out there
reacting to various clips.
Now as it happens, a
company called Jukin Media,
claims that the couple used
clips from Jukin database.
And Jukin appears to
be sort of a middleman
that goes about clearing
rights to various viral clips.
If they see that a video is trending,
they'll go out and they'll
reach out to the person
that created the clip
and they will get the ownership rights
to these various clips
so that they can license
those clips to other people.
- It used to be that they
would claim your videos
and take the revenue
from that video, right?
- Better than a strike.
- And so we started, you know,
removing their clips from our videos.
- Of course, because we're like,
okay, that's your clip,
so we won't use it.
- So basically, they just
strike our channel now,
whenever they see a clip.
- Some call Jukin Media a middleman,
they themselves analogize to Shutterstock,
where they buy rights to
various forms of media
and then sell it to other third parties.
Generally, you can buy a license
from Jukin on their website
to use their clips for $49 per clip.
Some called Jukin Media a copyright troll,
they specifically get viral clips
so that they can extort money
from other third parties.
I won't make a judgment call
as to whether they are doing
a good thing or a bad thing
for the internet.
But in this particular case,
it appears that MxR admit
they have used various clips
that belong to Jukin.
I don't know if you can actually owns
the rights to these clips.
But for the sake of argument,
let's assume that Jukin does in fact own
the copyright to these various clips.
In the past, Jukin has reached out to MxR
and they have demanded
$2,000 from the couple
for the couple's use
of various Jukin clips
in their YouTube channel.
- They email us with the bill
and they charged us $1,500 per
clip, that was in our videos.
And so today we got hit with a
huge bill of $6,000 in total.
- Jukin can came back
and demanded $6,000 more
for the use of four other clips
they didn't previously make a demand on.
It was at that point that
MxR went to the internet
and as one does when they
have a YouTube channel,
posted a video saying
that they were being extorted
by Julian for $6,000.
- So we've paid about $2,000 in total,
and now we have another $6,000 to pay.
And if you don't pay,
then basically they'll
start striking your channel.
- MxR claims that their
use of these videos
is fair use, of course,
and Jukin disputes that characterization.
The stakes here are incredibly
high in several respects.
Number one, Jukin is asking for $6,000,
which for many households,
that amount of money could
lead to financial ruin.
But additionally, when you
get attorneys involved,
$6,000 is a drop in the bucket
and we can be talking
about hundreds of
thousands of dollars here.
But on top of that, still,
we're talking about copyright strikes here
and Jukin has threatened
to issue copyright strikes against MxR,
which means that with
three copyright strikes,
potentially MxR's entire channel
could get deleted forever.
- Basically go through
an entire video library,
most likely find is
three instances of some,
you know, random clip,
and then they'll basically
remove our channel
if we don't pay them.
- And we don't really
have power against it.
We're stuck between a
hard place and a rock,
so I feel like they're just
constantly gonna extort us.
- So the stakes are incredibly high,
which by the way, is
why I created a course
for creators called copyrightcourse.com,
to deal with this exact situation
of where you are threatened
with copyright strikes
and what to do if you do
get a copyright strike
on your channel.
So let's talk about this exact situation
and the law that governs
this potential dispute.
Now, first a disclaimer, I
don't know all the facts,
I've gotten some of the facts from MxR,
which are going to be necessarily bias.
I've gotten some of the facts from Jukin,
which are also going to
be necessarily biased.
I don't know all the facts,
but one of the good
things about copyright law
is that often it just depends
on the underlying works themselves,
which we can look at and we can analyze.
So let's talk about
copyright law in general,
and specifically the copyrights.
One of the biggest myths on the internet
is that if something is out there,
you can use it for almost any purpose.
That's absolutely not the case.
If there is a clip on the
internet, someone owns it,
it might be hard to track them down.
But that clip, whether
it's a video, a sound file
or a picture, they belong to someone.
And the default position of copyright law
is that you need permission, a license,
to be able to use that underlying work,
whether it's a picture or
a video or what have you.
However, there's an exception
to that general rule,
that if you use that
media in a fair use way,
you don't need to get permission,
and you also don't have
to pay a license fee.
But if it's not fair
use, you do have to pay
and the rights holder can block you
from actually using that underlying media.
Fair Use is incredibly complex,
even judges get this wrong
and often judges say this is
the most complicated portion
of copyright law in all of jurisprudence.
But if you go to 17 USC 107,
you will find the Fair Use factors
to determine whether you're
using something in fair use.
The Fair Use clause states
that notwithstanding
the rest of the copyright act,
for purposes such as criticism, comment,
news reporting, teaching,
scholarship or research
is not an infringement of copyright.
And in determining whether
the use made of a work
in particular case is fair use,
the factors to be considered
shall include one,
the purpose and character of the use.
Two, the nature of the copyrighted work.
Three, the amount and
substantiality of the portion used
and four, the effect
upon the potential market
or value of the copyrighted work.
So let's talk about that really quickly.
So the first part of this section
of the Copyright Act says that,
generally things that are
for the purpose of commentary
and criticism can be considered fair use.
Now that's not dispositive.
But in order to get to
the rest of the factors,
you generally need a purpose
that is recognized by
the Fair Use statute.
Now that's not an exclusive
list of the things
that qualify as fair use.
But for intensive purposes,
let's assume that that's
the entire universe.
Now, there are four factors to determine
whether the actual use itself is fair use.
Now these are factors,
they're not elements,
you can't just check them off
and you have to balance
every single one of them.
Just because you win one factor,
doesn't mean that the use
is going to be fair use,
you have to balance all four together.
And the first factor is
by far the most important.
This is going to be a
gross oversimplification
because there are literally
millions of pages written
about fair use in American jurisprudence.
A quick summary of the first factor
is that this looks to the
transformativeness of the use,
assuming your purpose is
recognized by the Fair Use statute.
Let's assume commentary and criticism
because that's what most YouTube
use of media falls under.
Sometimes it's parody,
but usually it's commentary and criticism.
The first factor looks at
whether you have transformed
the purpose of the original clip itself.
So for example, a movie review.
A movie review often
uses clips from the movie
that it is reviewing,
but it would be very, very difficult
to be able to have a coherent criticism
or to be able to comment on a movie
without being able to use small portions
of the movie itself.
But how does a movie review
transform the underlying movie?
The purpose of a movie generally speaking
is for the entertainment value.
You watch a movie because
you're there to be entertained.
But a movie review itself
is not for the purpose of entertainment,
you're not usurping the
original purpose of the movie,
you are making a movie review
specifically to create
commentary and criticism
about that movie.
That is what we're talking about
when we're talking about
transformative nature of fair use.
And that's why the Copyright
Act specifically carves out,
commentary and criticism as a fair use.
So that is the fair use purpose,
plus the character of the
use, which is transformative.
The first factor is by
far the most important
and you can overcome a lot of sins
and the other three factors
if you have a highly
transformative use case
with a clearly fair use
commentary and criticism purpose
in your use.
So that takes me to the second factor,
the nature of the copyrighted work.
This generally looks to whether
the underlying work itself
is factual or fictional in nature.
Copyright doesn't want to give
people a monopoly over facts.
So as a result, factual works,
the things that actually
happened in real life,
tend to get less protection
than things that are fictional
and highly creative.
This tends to be actually
the least important
of the four factors.
Factor number three looks to the amount
and substantiality of the portion used
in relation to the
copyrighted work as a whole.
This is often summarized
by saying that people
are only allowed to use the
minimum amount necessary,
the bare minimum,
to be able to get their
commentary or criticism across.
So just because you're giving
commentary or criticism
doesn't mean you're allowed to use
the entire portion of the underlying work.
Sometimes you are, sometimes
the clips are very short,
sometimes you're only
dealing with the picture
which you kind of have
to use the whole thing.
But the bottom line is
that you generally can't
use the entire work itself
or you can't use the
heart of the work itself
in order to form your
commentary or criticism.
And finally, that takes
me to factor number four,
the effect of the use
upon the potential market
or value of the copyrighted work.
This is actually pretty
similar to the third factor.
The idea is that we don't
want people using things
in a fair use way that
usurps the entire market
for the original work.
If people are gonna watch your video
and not watch the original video
or not pay a license fee to the original,
then that's a factor that cuts
against your claim of fair use.
And it also kind of overlaps
with the first factor as well.
Because the less transformative your use,
the more likely you are to
use the original purpose
of the underlying work
and the more likely you are
to usurp the potential market
for the underlying work
and degrade the value of
that copyrighted work.
Now, if this all sounds
incredibly squishy and ambiguous,
you are entirely right.
That's sort of a feature not a bug though.
The purpose of fair use is that
this ambiguity and the
fact that it's squishy,
leads to flexibility,
so we can carve fair use into
whatever we need it to be
and we can apply it to new situations.
It's quite flexible.
The problem is often
you have to go to court
to be able to adjudicate these things.
And it also means that there
are absolutely no absolutes.
You can't say that all
reaction videos are fair use,
some are and some aren't,
it depends on the facts
of the particular case.
So now that you have a
reasonably good understanding
of what fair use means and its limitations
and its ambiguity,
let's look at the videos
that MxR actually used,
and which Jukin claims that MxR
now owes them thousands of
dollars for having used.
What MxR tends to do, is they
will take the general clip
and then they will inset their own video
in a small portion of
the rest of the frame.
They'll play the entire clip it seems
and then they will react to it.
So apparently Jukin
sent MxR a demand letter
that referenced for Jukin owned videos
that were used in three
MxR reaction videos.
On that basis, Jukin claim
that MxR owes them $6,000.
So let's look at these different videos.
So the first video that is at issue
is them reacting to a
video of a cat sticking
its tongue out.
It's only a couple seconds long.
I'm gonna zoom in on MxR
because I don't want to
infringe the copyright
of the cat video owner.
- It made me forget about the mayonnaise
and the maggots and the.
- So you can see it's
an incredibly short clip
and there's very minimal
commentary and criticism if any.
Generally speaking in copyright law,
you have to comment and
criticize the actual clip itself.
You can't use the clip to
comment on something else.
That's kind of the difference
between parody and satire.
Parody comments on the underlying work,
satire comments on something else.
Parody is fair use often but
satire is almost never fair use.
The next video is of MxR
reacting to a volcano exploding.
- Well that's.
Whoa, you see the shockwave?
- [Man] Watch out for the
shockwave it's coming.
- Did you see it?
Dude, that was awesome.
Wasn't that awesome Jeannie?
That was so awesome.
Do you want some water?
- So you can see here again,
they're only playing a small
portion of this volcano video,
but arguably that's the
heart of the volcano video.
You're not gonna watch the 20 minutes
of the volcano erupting.
The thing you want to see
is the volcano erupting.
And the commentary, if any,
is basically that's cool,
which is about as minimal as it gets.
Now in this third MxR video,
it appears that they've edited it
to remove the Jukin videos.
I actually couldn't find the videos
that Jukin references
in the demand letter.
I wonder if they have edited those out
or maybe I just wasn't paying attention.
Jukin references a girl doing a back flip
and guys lighting a
trail of leaves on fire.
I couldn't find that in
this underlying video.
But I do want to reference
what MxR says at the very
beginning of this video.
- So it's time once again
to get Jeannie to laugh.
I've come over yet another
brilliant compilation
of funny things all in the worthy endeavor
of making my beautiful
darling girlfriend laugh
because she deserves happiness.
- Sparkles.
- They point out that
Henry is showing Jeannie
these different videos
to see if he can get Jeannie to laugh.
In my estimation, that's not
really commentary or criticism.
That's not a transformative purpose.
And in fact, by showing those
clips in full to the audience,
arguably, they're using the clips
for the exact same purpose
as they were created
in the first place, to entertain people,
to try and get people to laugh.
And it's entirely possible
that you might not watch the Jukin videos,
because you saw basically the
whole thing in MxR's video.
So some of those Fair Use factors
might cut severely against
MxRs claim of fair use.
It's hard to say because
we don't have those clips
in this particular video.
And there might be more or less commentary
than in the prior two
videos that we looked at.
Now the last thing I wanna point out
is that in the beginning of this video,
Henry says that he's not going to display
the audio of a particular
clip, not a Jukin clip,
I don't think but another one
because he's worried about
getting a copyright claim related
to the music.
And that is bad when you're talking
about potential willful behavior,
which is an issue when it comes to damages
that we'll talk about in a second.
So there are a lot of bad
facts in this particular video.
In fact, some of these clips
might be dangerously close
to a hypothetical that I
use when I give speeches
about copyright and
explain things to creators.
An example of something that
you might think is fair use
that is clearly not fair use.
The example that I come up with
and this is not an actual case,
this is just me hypothesizing is that.
We recognize that movie
reviews are often fair use,
often quintessential fair use.
But imagine if you had a movie review
that had the entire movie itself,
the entire two hour long movie
and then at the end of the movie,
the movie reviewer said,
that was pretty good,
or I didn't really like that movie.
You've got commentary and criticism,
you've got some sort of
criticism about the movie,
it was good or it was bad.
But because you use the
entire movie itself,
that's clearly not the minimum necessary
and the commentary itself is
also just about as minimal
as it gets.
So the question of whether
MxR, Henry and Jeannie,
are actually doing something
that is fair use commentary
and criticism or copyright infringement
may turn on how courts have
looked at reaction videos
in the past.
So let's look at some of those cases.
And this is hilarious,
because one of those cases
involves Jukin Media itself.
Before we get to that,
let's talk about my favorite
fair use case of all time
and that is the h3h3Productions case.
In that particular case,
Hila and Ethan Kline,
the comedy duo behind h3h3Productions,
did a reaction video to a
video of a man named Matt Haas.
It was something along the lines
of park or girl versus workout guy,
which is a pretty cringe worthy thing
where a guy kind of stocks
a woman who's working out
on the street.
And in that video, they use almost all
of the entire clip itself,
but they are also peppering
the 10 minute long video
with lots and lots of commentary.
The Southern District of New York,
which is in the news for
many different reasons,
sided with Hila and Ethan and said that
this is a quintessential
commentary and criticism
and quintessential fair use,
and so they threw the case out.
Now, it was a bit of a Pyrrhic victory
because that required hundreds
of thousands of dollars
from Ethan and Hila Kline
to be able to get to that
stage of adjudication,
and that was taken out
in a very early stage,
on the motions, as we
say in the legal field,
it didn't even go to trial.
So if you go to trial,
you can expect to pay three
to four times as much.
I mean, honestly 800,000
to maybe a million dollars
to be able to adjudicate that.
So that takes us to
the Equals Three versus Jukin Media case,
a case that actually
involves Jukin Media itself.
This is a case that is pretty similar.
You have a YouTube clip show
that is owned by Equals Three,
and they are reacting to a particular clip
that is owned by Jukin.
This case involved close
to 20 different clips,
but here's one that is sort of emblematic
of the rest of them.
Jukin owned a video of a bear getting
his head stuck in a bucket,
and some construction
workers used to crane
to get the bucket off of the bears head.
The clip show used almost
all of the clip itself
and then proceeded to talk about it
for roughly about a minute.
- Every time a bear gets his.
Winnie the Pooh, it just, it gets me.
- And regarding this particular clip,
the court cited with Equals Three,
and found that this was in fact fair use.
If you were to ask me,
what is the case that shows
the absolute bare minimum
of commentary necessary
to make a fair use claim?
I might point you to Equals
Three versus Jukin Media,
which is why I have cited to that case
in almost all of my videos
that rely on fair use clips.
But this case is a bit of a mixed bag.
The court decided as a matter of law
that most of these clips were fair use,
but also decided that some
could not be adjudicated,
so those would have to
go to a jury to decide.
And at that point, the
parties settled out of court.
So it's a bit of a mixed bag
and Jukin might have been
right on some of those clips.
Now, if you want an in depth analysis
of the Equals Three
versus Jukin Media case,
check out my friend
Leonard French's channel,
he goes into a huge amount of detail
about this particular case exactly.
The bottom line is that this would be
an incredibly close call.
MxR skating dangerously close to the line
of it being not fair use.
But there's authority on both sides.
And in fact, one of the cases
that I would use against Jukin Nedia
if I was representing MxR
is a case involving Jukin Media itself.
But arguments can be made on both sides.
If I was representing MxR, which I'm not,
I'm not your attorney and
this is not legal advice.
I would advise them not to go to court
because I'd be worried that
number one, they would lose.
And even if they won, they would probably
have to go all the way through
trial and take it to a jury,
which would incur
potentially a million dollars
in attorneys fees.
And by the same token, stop admitting to.
Stop going online and admitting
not only to liability,
but potentially evidence that
could give rise to liability.
Stop posting videos and
stop going on Twitter
and lawyer up and talk
about what your rights are
before you start digging
yourself into a bigger hole
than you already have.
On the other hand, if I
was Jukin Media's attorney,
which I'm not, this is not legal advice,
I would probably tell them the same thing,
that this is not something
you'd want to go to court over,
they've lost on this before.
And that you're dealing with potentially
not only losing this
battle, not only in court,
but in the court of public opinion,
but potentially attorneys
fees are on the line.
One of the things about copyright law
is that sometimes the loser has to pay
the winners attorneys
fees, it gets really dicey.
I don't know that this
is one of those cases,
but it could be on the line.
But they're bad facts and
there's bad law for both sides.
This is not something
that either side wants
to take to court.
And the stakes are incredibly large.
I talked about earlier,
that MxR might be on the
hook not just for the $6,000
that Jukin requests,
but actually $600,000.
The reason is that when you're
talking about copyright law,
not only do you have to deal with
what are called the actual damages,
the out of pocket loss
that someone has suffered,
but you also have statutory damages.
And in some circumstances,
where you have a willful act
by the copyright infringer,
you can get $150,000 per infringement.
So those four different videos
that may or may not have
constituted copyright infringement
could mean that MxR was on the hook
for $600,000 in statutory damages,
that would be up to the court.
On top of that, attorneys
fees are on the table as well,
which might even be more than $600,000
if this was taken to court,
not to mention since we're
dealing with DMCA takedowns
and YouTube strikes,
that their channel might be deleted,
which I assume is their
major source of income
for the household.
- It's just constantly in the fear
of our channel being deleted.
- So given the thousands,
potentially millions of dollars at stake,
is this extortion by Jukin Media
against Henry and Jeannie at MxR?
Well, almost certainly not,
at least not the legal
definition of extortion.
This might constitute the sort
of colloquial understanding
of extortion, of bad guy
pushing a small person around,
but it's almost certainly
not legal extortion.
We'll talk about whether Jukin
is a copyright troll in a second,
but in general to be able to
form a claim for extortion
under at least the federal
statute in 18 USC 1951,
you have to have a wrongful claim.
It has to be disconnected
from a claim of right.
Jukin claims to have a good faith belief
that this is copyright infringement.
And on the facts as I see them,
they could very well have a
meritorious copyright claim.
It's hard to say, it could go either way.
But because of that,
essentially, what they're doing
is they're just making a demand,
which potentially is legal against someone
who was a potential copyright infringer.
Jukin Media actually left a comment
on MxR's YouTube channel, saying,
"hi, we'd like the chance
to respond to this.
"For starters, it's
important to understand
"that we provide a service
for video creators.
"We allow them to list
their content on our website
"so that TV shows publishers,
YouTubers, influencers
"or advertisers can buy a
license to use their content.
"We have no ill will
towards you or your channel.
"In effect, you're taking
other people's videos
"without asking them then
posting them to your channel
"and making money off of them.
"We never want to issue copyright strikes,
"we have a duty to do so to protect
"the copyright of the creators
who have signed with us.
"Again, there's no reason
we can't work together
"so that you can have
access to amazing videos
"and that creators of those
videos share in the economics."
Of course, Jukin says they don't want
to issue DMCA takedowns.
And the reason is because
there are actual legal repercussions
for levying those DMCA takedown notices.
So, of course, they don't want to do that
and they don't want to
take people to court
because it's incredibly
expensive, and they might lose.
But that's why some
people call Jukin Media
a copyright troll.
They get the copyrights
to various viral videos
and then make demands for serious money
from people that have used
those clips in other media.
I reached out to both MxR and Jukin
about this particular dispute.
Jukin got back to me and
provided this statement,
they say that they did consider fair use,
but they feel that MxR's videos don't rise
to the level of fair use
and they point out that they
have paid out over $20 million
to people whose videos they have licensed.
But we don't know what
percentage of Jukin revenue comes
from making these demands,
versus proactively
licensing this material.
And in some sense, having
middlemen like this
can be a very good thing
because it's often very, very hard
to know who owns the rights
to these various things.
Someone owns the rights
to these viral clips,
but often big businesses will not use them
because they might not be able
to track down who owns them,
and having a middleman, like Jukin
can help solve that problem
and create revenue from licensing
that otherwise simply wouldn't exist.
Now, if you want more detail about
whether this constitutes extortion
and the requirements for extortion,
I recommend checking out
fellow YouTube lawyer,
Richard Hoeg's channel,
where he goes into a
lot of depth about this.
Now, I disagree with him
about the dollar amounts
themselves being potential
evidence of a claim of extortion.
Actually $1,500 per offense
is a pretty small amount
if I'm honest.
I know it can be a huge amount
to small YouTubers out there
but in the world of copyright law,
it's a very, very small amount
and it is dwarfed by the
potential devastating effects
of statutory damages or
an award of attorneys fees
in an actual lawsuit over this case.
One of the more famous extortion cases
is the case of Autumn
Jackson and Bill Cosby.
Autumn Jackson claimed
that she was the daughter of Bill Cosby
before he was outed as a sexual predator
and extorted him,
said that she would ruin
his squeaky clean reputation
in the news media
by sowing these potentially
untrue allegations
that he had fathered her out of wedlock.
And one of the cases that
Richard Hoeg mentions
in his video about this case
is the Michael Avenatti case, is ongoing.
It hasn't led to a resolution.
But one of the things
that Michael Avenatti
is accused of having done
is to extort a settlement out of Nike,
not for his clients,
but for a multi million dollar
consulting gig for himself.
Lawyers are not allowed to
negotiate on their own behalf
at the expense of their clients.
And so that could conceivably
give rise to extortion.
Michael Avenatti just
lost a motion to dismiss
that legal claim.
So it's going to go to trial.
We'll see if he's convicted on that.
But when a lawyer tries to
get something from a party
that they're not legally
allowed to ask for,
like a consulting gig
worth millions of dollars
for their own behalf,
that could potentially
give rise to extortion.
Whereas here, mainly what's happening
is that Jukin is asking for payment
for copyright infringement.
And as we've talked about before,
whether copyright
infringement occurred or not,
or whether it's fair use or not,
is certainly an open question.
By the way, some have said that YouTube
should just shut this down.
Jukin is abusing the copyright system,
regardless of the underlying claims,
and that YouTube should
just remove their ability
to make these claims.
Well, the problem is, this
isn't really YouTube's system.
This is not content ID.
What Jukin is talking about
here is issuing a DMCA takedown.
This is written into the
Copyright Act section 512.
If there is infringing
material on a website,
including YouTube,
you are allowed to issue a DMCA notice
and have it taken down.
YouTube has implemented a version of that
which incurs a strike
when you get a DMCA claim.
But there are also ways
to fight DMCA claims,
which I've covered in my copyright course.
So effectively YouTube
has to follow the law.
When they get a DMCA claim,
they have to take the video
down, they can't ignore it
and they can't stop people
from issuing DMCA claims.
It's written into the copyright law
that they just basically have to follow.
And if Jukin does actually have a claim,
then they have every right
to issue a DMCA takedown.
Now, the Ninth Circuit
law under lens says that
they have to have a good faith belief
that they have a claim
of copyright infringement
and they have taken into
consideration Fair Use
before they have issued
that DMCA takedown.
But look, if they have a claim,
they have a right to issue a DMCA takedown
and a copyright strike.
This is serious business.
I get copyright claims all
the time on my channel,
but I'm very confident
in my fair use because,
number one, I have a law degree.
I have over a decade of
experience as a trial lawyer
and copyright lawyer.
And I know what I'm talking about.
The big businesses have lawyers
who know this stuff inside and out
because the operative word
here is that it is a business.
And we've talked about the
copyright implications.
But let's talk about these sort of,
business law related things here.
And even though I am not MxR lawyer,
and this is #notlegaladvice,
what I can say to MxR
is you need a lawyer.
This is a business and
you can't go around,
just floundering around,
thinking that you're going to be safe.
I asked my friend Roberto Blake,
who knows the business of
YouTube better than everyone
what he thought about this situation
and here's what he said.
- I think when you are a
full time content creator,
when you have a very significant channel,
like in this situation, that you have
to really think of things like a business
and you have to deal with
Jukin Media like a business.
They aren't really gonna care too much
about the court of public opinion.
This isn't like a YouTube drama situation,
where calling them out,
really is that meaningful.
YouTubers tend to get
very invested emotionally
in these situations,
when the real answer is to step back,
treat it like a business
and call your lawyer
and let them deal with it
because this is a business
to business situation
and you really want to
play your best cards.
And when you take the step of just trying
to out them in social media
or do something like that,
you're playing more the
game like a YouTuber
than like an entrepreneur
and a business person
that's trying to protect
what they've built.
- And that's exactly right.
There are huge consequences here.
And you have to lawyer up either way.
MxR says that they don't have a lawyer.
Well, they need to get one.
And Jeannie says that she
spent half an hour going
through Jukin videos.
Well, number one, that is not enough time.
And number two, you can't unring the bell.
Some have argued that look, Jukin admits
that the licence fee is only $50,
why can't MxR just pay $200,
$50 for each video,
and then everyone can
go on their merry way?
Well, the problem is that you're dealing
with copyright here.
Once you have committed
copyright infringement,
and I'm not saying that MxR
has committed copyright infringement
or that they can't use
the Fair Use defense.
They may not have committed infringement,
and they may have that defense.
If you infringe the copyright,
you can't then go back
through the database
and buy the license,
that's simply not enough.
There's statutory fees,
which are potentially huge,
and it costs money to
get lawyers involved.
So once the horse is out of the barn,
you can't put it back in again.
If you steal a car,
you can't avoid jail time by
giving it back to the owner.
And it seems the MxR has
already dug themselves
further into the hole
by not having a lawyer.
They said that they already
paid $2,000 to Jukin,
related to two different videos,
and then Jukin came back.
Well, when you feed the trolls
they come back for more.
- Clearly, I realized our
mistake was paying the first time
because now they're like,
we have we have someone
we could just easily
just get easy money out of.
- A competent lawyer probably
would have made Jukin sign
a release of all claims,
so that MxR wouldn't admit
liability and it would make sure
that Jukin couldn't come back for more
after they paid the $2,000.
But because they didn't sign a release,
Jukin can come back over
on adjudicated claims,
which is exactly what Jukin did.
Additionally, a lawyer would
have negotiated it down.
Jukin has basically admitted
that a reasonable license
for these clips is $49,
which would mean that an MxR
should pay $150, not $6,000.
But the problem is that
because they didn't have any foresight,
they didn't have a lawyer,
they didn't know what they were doing
when it came to copyright,
they could be liable for thousands more,
not just the $6,000 that Jukin claims,
but potentially hundreds
of thousands of dollars
in statutory fees.
Also a word of caution to MxR,
MxR has already linked to a video
that takes MxR's side by a
channel called TheQuartering.
I'd be very careful about
listening to that advice.
- I strongly suggest MxR stand
up and tell them to get bent
and tell him to sue them.
And when they issue a copyright
strike on the channel,
I would dispute it and I
would say take me to court.
I don't think they're willing
to do that as a company,
but it's not my money.
- I'm sorry if this sounds
harsh, but Jukin claim
isn't necessarily facially invalid.
This is a case that could go either way.
What MxR has done might be fair use,
but it also might not be fair use.
It would be up to a judge or jury,
and reasonable minds can differ.
That's what happens when you go to court.
You kind of roll the dice.
Certainly lawyers who I've
talked to about this very case
have differing ideas about it.
And I would love love to tell you that MxR
is clearly in the right and
Jukin is clearly in the wrong.
I hate the way that they've gone about,
trying to get money from MxR,
but I don't know that that's the case.
I love creators and I want
them to create more art,
but we all have to operate
within the confines
of the way the law actually is,
not the way that we want it to be.
And it's possible, maybe even
probable that MxR is wrong.
And MxR isn't quite as
small as they claim,
they can't stick their head in the sand.
Trolls like this go out and
they look for deep pockets.
The thing is, Jukin has
taken this to court before
and effectively they've won.
We don't know the actual outcome
because there was a settlement
but odds are Jukin got the
better of that particular case.
And even winning can be losing
in a situation like this.
Vindicating your rights
could easily take half a million
dollars in attorneys fees,
just ask Ethan Kline from h3h3,
it took hundreds of thousands of dollars,
They went through $200,000 in one month
to ultimately be
successful in their claim.
So don't assume that you can
start a GoFundMe over that.
Jukin doesn't care about
what you think about it.
A judge doesn't care
about your Twitter clout
or bad Yelp reviews.
So just be very careful about
whose advice you listen to.
And again, the best thing you
can do is talk to an attorney.
And I've represented clients on both sides
of the copyright coin.
I've represented clients
who have had to defend
against meritless claims of infringement,
and I've also represented clients
who have had their works stolen by others
and had to defend their rights.
It's always a big deal
and it's always messy.
And as Roberto Blake said,
they need to think about
their YouTube channel
as a business.
MxR plays gets 900,000
views on average per day,
sometimes well over a million views a day.
At a conservative CPM of
$6 with the YouTube split,
if monetized their channel
would get roughly $2,500
to $3,000 per day,
that equates to a
million dollars per year.
That's not a small business,
that is a medium sized business,
and they need a lawyer.
Now I understand that
there's a controversy
about whether their YouTube
channel is monetized or not.
But I also understand that they have 10s
of thousands of patrons on Patreon.
And at a minimum, if they're
paying one to $2 per month,
that means that they're
earning potentially
a quarter of a million dollars per year
just on Patreon alone.
You can't get away with thinking
that this is just mere YouTube drama.
This is real life.
The stakes are incredibly high.
There are hundreds of thousands
of dollars at stake here.
You might end up in federal court
and this is not just a
word of warning to MxR,
but this is a warning to
anyone with a YouTube channel.
MxR says that they're worried
they might have to stop reacting to videos
and that they might just
react to pictures instead.
Number one, if you are doing
things in a fair use way,
then there's no need to stop.
But I think they need to ask themselves
whether they are very, very certain
that they have met the
Fair Use requirement.
- And at this point, it's like,
I feel like we can't even
watch any videos anymore.
We can't react to any videos period.
- Like we can only look
at images and pictures.
- And I will say that it is just a myth
that they could forego the videos
and start reacting to pictures instead,
because pictures are copyrighted as well
and they might run into
exactly the same problems
that they run into with video,
which is one of the reasons I gave a talk
called the 11 myths of
copyright on the internet.
If you're a content creator,
and you would like to see this free video,
you can check out the
link in the description.
It's part of my course that I
created for creators out there
who don't have lawyers necessarily
but they need to be protected
when they're making
videos on the internet.
That's why I created copyrightcourse.com.
It is specifically created for creators
to tell them what their rights are
and to give them the tools that they need
when they find themselves
looking down the barrel
of a copyright strike,
potentially getting their channel deleted.
It gives them the tools that they need,
including the actual language
that I have used as an attorney
to fight off dozens of
different copyright claims
by underlying rights holders.
I have never lost a claim
because as I said before,
I know what I'm doing
and you can use the exact
same templates that I use
when I am fighting copyright
trolls on the internet.
So check out the links in the description,
you can check out the free
video, 11 myths of copyright,
or you can go straight
to copyrightcourse.com
to get the copyright course
which I created so that other creators
will not be in the same situation
that MxR Plays find themselves in.
So, do you agree with my analysis?
Do you think that MxR is being extorted
or that maybe they committed
light copyright infringement?
How do you think that this
would turn out in court
based on the precedents
that we talked about here?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
that contains all of my
other Real Law reviews,
where I talk about legal
issues in the news,
including impeachment
and tons of other
copyright related things.
And check it out and I
will see you in court.